If all of your norms are the way to get
rich is to just make short-term bets,
you actually may know know more people
in your real life that made money from
short-term bets than long-term bets.
>> Yes. Look at the 20 software companies
that you respect the most. Tell me which
one of those blew up super fast. Which
one was like they made it in a year?
None. And I'm like, what is that? What
does that mean?
All right. This is Dalton plus Michael
and we're going to talk about some
advice for young people now that we are
in this AI era.
>> Yeah,
>> this is the AI era, right?
>> Yeah, we're we're in the AI.
>> It's hard to name the era when you're in
it.
>> We're in it. Yeah, we're in it.
>> I'm going to set this up, Jan. I'm going
to give you the controversial first
thing to bounce off of. Super
intelligent is imminent. We might be
entering the, you know, end of days. How
much of the pre-a advice even applies
anymore? You know, I'm a young person.
Like, are we not in a break glass in
case of emergency zone where I need to
ignore everything and just like go nuts,
start my company, do whatever I'm going
to do like like like you know, it's like
time is of the essence. I mean, look, in
some ways, time is of the essence in
that if you're paying attention to
what's going on and you're learning the
tools and you're in the right place at
the right time,
>> it's a really good move. Um, and so
there is a there actually is an argument
that being strategic about what you
spend time on, who you spend time on,
what you learn is smart,
>> especially in the beginning of an era,
right? you get a lot of extra juice if
you're early on a skill set in the
beginning of an era, right? So, that's
that is totally true and you should
think about that and we can talk about
that in a second. In addition though, I
think there's something about doomsday
culture. I don't know what you want to
call it, but there's something about
kind of pseudo religious stuff that gets
people going that they just happen to be
alive in the time that the world is
going to end and that if they do a good
thing then they'll be rewarded for it
and then everyone else is in trouble.
>> Yeah, this rhymes with some things in
humans past. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Sounds familiar, right? Um and
certainly, you know, to let me try to
steal man a little bit. Certainly, I've
talked to people that believe that they
have a short window to try to make their
way in the world and make money before
AGI happens and that it'll be much
harder in a post AGI world for them to
be set up. I'm trying to steal man that
argument, but I've heard people make it.
Yes.
>> Can you make that a strong Can you make
a better version of that or is that did
I make the best version?
>> I mean, I do think there's this kind of
argument that if AGI exists, does the
startup world still exist?
>> I think it's just start I think it's
everything. Like I I've spoken to try to
steal man. I've spoken to folks that are
like drop out of college. They're not
teaching you anything that's useful.
>> Every minute you spend doing that stuff
is like downside.
>> I suppose it before where college was
teaching you everything you needed to
know.
>> I don't know. I I'm not going to touch
that one. Um but basically break the
glass. Um, you know, do do whatever you
can do because there's something about
this moment that anything not spent on
some sort of AGI pill type life
trajectory is a bad call.
>> To further that amongst startup
founders, what I've seen is the if my
thing is not scaling to 100 million in
revenue within a year, it's a bad idea.
I need to pivot away from it because
like cursor and lovable or what you know
whatever the startup of the moment is is
taking off and I'm I'm not on the right
rocket ship. You know it's such a good
point. This is the fundamental tension
in all the advice that we've ever given
over all the years is that you have to
simultaneously
be impatient
and ambitious and have feel like you
have a hair on fire thing to be
ambitious.
And at the same time, in your same
brain, hold the idea that doing great
work takes a long time. Isn't that so
hard? And like, and again, how many
times have we talked to people that are
frustrated that they're like, "Aren't
you aren't you kind of contradicting
yourself, Dalton? Aren't you?"
>> Yes.
>> It's like, "Yes, that is
>> that is exactly right."
>> Yes.
>> You you have to be insanely impatient to
do great work and to push the world that
wants to move slow to move fast.
>> Yes. And you have to set yourself up to
not freak out and quit. Doing good work
takes time. Solving hard problems takes
time.
>> Yeah. And learning a skill takes time.
Yeah. It was really funny. I was talking
to this founder. He B2B company. And you
know his kind of stated goal is a little
pound tree like he wants to go into your
company, understand their data using AI
and help them solve their biggest
problem. And he said this thing to me
that like kind of blew my mind. He's
like, "Yeah, we got in there, learned
about their biggest problem, we learned
what was causing it. That seemed too
hard to solve." So, we spent four months
searching for other problems that'd be
easier to solve. And it was like, and
then I'm like, "And did you find it?"
Like, not nothing that important. And
it's like, I almost think about it like
um the way I describe it, and maybe I've
done this in previous videos, is an SAT
math problem. Like, people have been
taught that when the SAT math problem
gets too hard, they're probably doing it
wrong. And so it's like, oh, you don't
really need algebra for most SAT
problems. Like, you're probably not
thinking about the problem the right
way. And I think people apply that to
startups where it's like, oh, if
something is too hard, that means I'm
doing something wrong. I should be
searching for an easy.
>> Yeah. And it's like, what's the Peter
Teal quote? There was something like
he's like, everything that is valuable
is hard, but not everything that is hard
is valuable. The first part of that,
like everything that is valuable is
hard. Well, it's funny you brought up
Palunteer and I'm not saying I'm the
world's biggest expert on it, but man,
>> I knew some early employees
>> that went nowhere. Like, they basically
had to just toil in obscurity for many
years and now it's like a meme stock and
I think young people all know about it
because of the stock price, but I think
they started that company in like 2002.
It's been like 23 or 24 years and I
think for the first 10 maybe even 15
years it was kind of belittled. That's
just the consulting company. Like that's
the gov tech. Like that's not cool.
>> And talk about folks who've
>> on hard problems for a long time. This
duality that you're talking about is
important. My advice to people when they
encountering this is like I don't sit
well with this duality. I don't sit well
with like I've got to move fast and it's
going to take a long time in parallel.
So I just like to make it a serial
problem. When I was young starting a
company, it feels like an emergency. We
got to nuclear fast. I'm ignoring it's
going to take time. Yeah. Now that I'm
in the company, oh crap. Okay.
You know, now that I'm committed, the
thing's going d Now I kind of move on to
this other belief. Oh crap. Okay. Like
we're not going to be able to solve any
of the hard problems super fast. You got
to get to that second point.
>> Well, it's like you got to keep showing
up. U was talking to someone about our
videos. This is meta. Yeah. But
basically, how many videos we made, man?
I think we made 60 or so so far.
>> Yeah.
>> No one does that. Like a lot of people
start YouTube channels and they make one
or two but didn't blow up.
>> It didn't blow up.
>> That didn't go viral.
>> And but like to actually build something
that matters to people, you have to like
keep doing it. And so so to tie this
into advice for for AGI and all that
good stuff, I mean it is great to be
impatient. It's great to want to drop
everything to learn the tools. Yes. But
you have to combine that. Yes.
>> With a willingness to sit with something
and to really to do great work. It's
gonna take a while. And so whether
that's school, whether that's job stuff,
whether that's startup stuff. I was
reading uh something by uh this guy
recently. I think he called it the
casinoification of modern capitalism and
how many young folks are used to the way
they implicitly are trained to believe
that the way you build wealth is from
sports gambling. It's a huge part of
being young,
>> crypto, stock gambling, zero dated
options, like all this stuff is all kind
of casino stuff. And so if ever if all
of your norms are the way to get rich is
to just make short-term bets and you
know people that made money from
short-term bets kind of what we're
saying is not going to land for you. You
actually may know know more people in
your real life that made money from
short-term bets than longterm bets.
>> Real money for most people is
>> sports betting winning money. You know,
I was talking to a founder about this
and the quote unquote anecdote I tried
to give him to this feeling in his head
was just like, look at the 20 software
companies that you respect the most. And
just like tell me which one of those
blew up super fast. Like which which
which one was like they made it in a
year. He's like none. And I'm like what
does that what does that mean? Like come
on.
Because I to me this also happens in
startups so much where it's like oh well
they raised a series A in two months and
I'm like when did series A become the
end point like when when did that become
the like victory like run through the
line get the gold medal point like it
never like raising a series A means you
have a 90% chance of death I think it's
a little higher
>> there we go great at least 90% chance of
death could be higher
>> depending on which investor gives you
serious it I round to 100%.
>> I think I think we're going to do better
than that. But I think we're going to do
better than that.
>> But anyways, and the thing that triggers
this for me was a conversation I had
with some very smart technical founders
coming out of Stanford maybe three or
four years ago and they said this line
to me that I will never forget. We were
taught that all consumer startups suck
and that it's only possible to build a
B2B company. any Stanford administration
listening, um maybe they're misquing
you, but anyways, um it was so
interesting because it's almost like
they wanted to be given the rules to win
the game. Like they were so seeking like
please give me a framework. If I do A,
B, C, and D,
>> I win.
And this kind of nuggets slot slotted
right like regardless of what I'm
interested in slot A is it has to be a
B2B SAS company and slot B is this and
slot C is this and then like if I do
that I win.
>> It's such a good point because so many
people think that there's an answer
there's a secret and that we have it.
People like us have it.
>> Yeah. Um, I think if you watch our
videos, you'll we we tell you what we
know, but I don't think there's like a
clip you could take out of one of the
videos where like, "Oh, they said the
secret." And it's funny because I'm sure
you get these emails, too, but there's a
lot of people that are like, "The advice
that you give in 15 minutes will change
everything." Can you imagine actually
believing that talking to us for 15
minutes would help whatever someone's
problems are.
>> Well, I'll say especially after all
these videos.
>> Yeah. I mean, what are we going to say?
the likelihood in 15 minutes they're
going to say more than
>> but but the point is I think people
think that there's like an optimal path
or set of directions.
>> Yes.
>> Like this is a video game and there's
like a cheat guide. Here's how you get
to the here's how you get through the
maze and that if someone just tells you
how to get through the maze, it's like
really trivial. Yeah.
>> And it just bears repeating over and
over again. The people that made it
through the maze gritted through it and
it wasn't that someone gave them a
really easy hack. I love seeing in this
video game frame. There's the cheat code
in the video game, right? Like, oh, you
get more lives, you get to warp to the
end, and then there's the guide book
that's just like, here's exactly how to
do every step. I think neither of them
apply in startups.
>> Yeah.
>> Like, and I think when people search for
them, is specifically that guide book. I
think the cheat book is, you know, we
talked about that with crypto and stuff.
I think that guide book that's what I'm
kind of starting to call the
MBAification
of of of startup founders where it's
kind of like MBAs were originally
created to train middle managers. Yep.
>> And if you're bringing a middle manager
into a company, there is a guide book.
There's a guide book on how to get in.
There's a guide book on what to do.
There's a guide book on how to get
promoted. Like
>> it's like they teaching you the
fundamentals of finance.
>> Yep.
>> Teaching you the fundamentals of uh
management. Like it's it was like
General Motors, right? It was basically
these really big companies needed a to
hire middle managers.
>> Yes.
>> And so these were training these were
trade schools.
>> These were trade schools for middle
managers and they would fund the
business school like they would donate
money to start this thing up. And I
think that like that has been
transposed on this startup thing which
was always a extremely high-risk
irregular
plans need to change all the times
luckbased like it it was I can't think
of anything more opposite than being a
middle manager at GM. And what
frustrates me is that everyone knows
there's no guidebook to being Michael
Jordan, right? like everyone knows like
you know you can do everything he did
and you know just like but yet people
cause themselves to believe no if I just
follow this set of rigid best practices
successful company comes out the back
and it's like
>> no I understood this being a belief of
MBA folks right if you go to business
school for two years it'll infect you
this is now young technical founders
>> are are
being taught this stuff It's so
frustrating because it's kind of like
these rules and best practices won't
save you. Like you're still going to
have to do something extremely hard and
be lucky and it's going to be at the
limit of your abilities. There's no
guide book for that. As a quick aside, I
remember the story this band in England
made a guide book on how to write a
number one single. Okay?
>> And they sold it as a book and that a
one band actually did it and tried it
and it worked.
>> Okay? And the song they made was Chumba
Womba tub thumping.
And it was like a satirical book, but
they did it literally where they're
like, "Here's how you write a number one
single." And I guess Chumba Womba
followed the book and wrote a number one
hit single. And by the way, I'm sure
they made a lot of money on that book
after that single.
But I think that like maybe you know to
close for the advice to young people I
always tell founders like make sure that
you're having fun because to your point
about you're going to have to stick with
it for a long time. I have not seen
people be able to stick with hard
challenges for a long time when they're
not having fun. And when they are having
fun I've seen them do crazy stuff. Yeah.
Like literally crazy. How many times
have we seen people do good work that
they're proud of fast? It's almost like
being able to take pride in your work
and being proud of your body work
involves putting many years into it.
Yes.
>> And that you almost want to normalize
that or we want to tell you got to tell
people yeah this is what's normal is uh
sustained periods of long work to do
something good and not
>> hitting a lottery ticket. And I think
even in this age of or era of AI, you
have time to do great work like we are
in the very beginning of it. So with
that, thanks Dalton. Thank you.
[Music]